Dave here and this is Rueben report I've
been really inspired by the reaction to
the interview with Sam I knew that I
felt really passionately about the
issues we talked about and needed to
address the campaign to discredit him
and I knew a lot of other people felt
the same way but I think I actually
underestimated just how badly people
wanted this conversation to happen from
YouTube comments to the tweets to people
who wrote me literally pages of thoughts
on Facebook and email there was a real
sense that it was cathartic for people
who were feeling the same thing I was
that's exactly what I want this show to
be so I'm really proud that we got off
to the right start if we're gonna build
some kind of community here based on the
principles that I laid out last week and
put in action in the interview with Sam
I think I have to ask something of you
now many of you were giving me kudos for
having an honest dialogue but if we
really want to change things it's gonna
have to be way bigger than just me I'm
sure some of you know that I'm gay
actually I got gay married two weeks ago
which is pretty gay it's pretty much the
gayest thing you can do I don't really
bring it up anymore unless it's related
to something in the news and I don't
want any extra credit for it or anything
like that
we got equality there's still work to do
but we've done great things that are
moving forward that's how progress is
supposed to work a couple years ago I
hosted a podcast in a Sirius XM show
called the six-pack it was a pop culture
a new show with celebrity guests aimed
at the LGBT community the show was
really different than most gay culture
out there and that it was hosted by two
guys who just happened to be gay but we
didn't make everything about being gay I
mentioned this because we used to get a
ton of email from people saying how much
we were helping them come to terms with
themselves come out of the closet talk
to friends and family and all that stuff
even more than that though we got a ton
of email from people saying they were
still closeted and our show was their
only gay outlet one day this strange
paradox hit me the people that we were
helping the most by doing the show the
people who were closeted and had no
other outlet were the same people who
helped us as a show the least and that
they couldn't tweet about us or share
posts about us on Facebook or even tell
their friends about us I really
struggled with this in my relationship
to the audience because I knew that
closeted life all too well and I know
that if the situation had been reversed
I would have been one of those people
like I said before I think we're on to
something really special here we're
going to be part of something that takes
back liberal
for true liberals but to do that we have
to be louder we have to be braver and
bolder to say what we think and share it
with the people we know I noticed a lot
of the people with the word atheism in
their usernames have anonymous profiles
on Twitter and some even on Facebook
we all of our reasons I'm not passing
judgment on anyone here but think about
that for a woman in 2015
atheists are one of the last groups of
people that feel like they have to be
anonymous when they say what they really
feel again this isn't everybody or even
the majority but it seems to be a bigger
portion than it should be and believe me
I get it I was closeted for a long time
you might have family that won't accept
you as an atheist or maybe your
community won't or maybe you aren't
fully sure what you are I don't want to
make this just about atheists though I
think all of us secular people have to
be seen and heard more let's not just
talk about it with each other let's get
other people in on the conversation too
we don't need to go out and find
converts they'll find us because that's
what humanism and secularism does by
default we just have to be louder it's
not going to be easy all three of the
people who Sam and I talked about who
continuously misrepresent him have done
so again publicly since our interview
feel free to check out my Twitter feed
to see the latest nonsense these people
are simply not going to stop if we want
to be heard we have to clearly fight
back with logic on our side so if you
hear me if you dig what we've started
here and you want it to get bigger and
better then like share comment post and
do whatever the hell else there is the
forces of anti-intellectualism and
radicalism are always on the march let's
get our voices heard so that we can win
not by violence but by ideas remember as
obi-wan said to Luke the force is what
gives a Jedi his power it's an energy
field created by all living things it
surrounds us and penetrates us it binds
the Galaxy together but if you don't
post about it on Facebook nobody will
know
you